Hello and welcome to this video on the scatter tool exercise, where we will be using the
construction script.
Now there is no project which comes with this course.
What I will be using is the third person template from the games category.
I'm going to make sure that I have the starter content ticked on, because we're going to
be using some of the meshes which come with this.
I'll just push create.
And once that's loaded up, you should get a project which looks something like this.
The only thing that I'm going to do slightly differently, so I'm going to come down, I'm
going to select the content drawer, and I will dock that in the viewport.
We're going to be working with assets quite a lot, so I'd like them to be visible.
For this first scattering tool, what we will do is we'll develop a tool that enables a
random scattering of meshes throughout the scene.
This tool will provide options for adjusting the scatter distance and selecting the meshes
that we want to use, also determining the number of meshes that you want it to generate.
And all of this we're going to do on construction script.
So to start with, I'm going to right-hand click and I'm going to select a blueprint
class.
For this, I am going to select the actor class.
I'm going to call this BP underscore scatter tool.
I'm going to double click to open this up.
Now the first thing that I'm going to want to do is select the tab for construction script
up here in the center.
Now it's going to bring us to this page where we just have one purple node popping out here.
And to start with, I'm going to drag off and search for print string.
Then just compile and save.
This is just so that we can see when the construction script fires.
I'm going to jump back into the map and I'll drag this into the level.
And straight away you can see that we have a massive great big list of hello down the
left-hand side here.
So that's just to demonstrate when it triggers.
The construction script will trigger whenever the actor is placed in the level or whenever
anything is updated, such as his transform here as I drag it around.
Okay, we can jump back into the tool.
I'm going to delete this print string.
We don't need that anymore.
And I'm going to generate some variables, because how we're going to control what the
script does is by exposing some variables.
So the first one we want, if we push plus here, first one is going to be spawnable meshes.
And this is going to be of the type static mesh.
Just search for static.
And you'll see we here we have an option for static mesh.
I'm just going to select the object reference.
You see it turns blue because this is a reference.
Now there's a couple more things I need to do with this.
So the first thing is, we're going to want to allow numerous static meshes to be added
to this tool.
So rather than it being just a single static mesh that's referenced, in the drop down,
I'm going to select an array.
This will allow us to add multiple meshes.
And the last thing I'm going to do is you can see that we have an option here for instance
editable.
Now if I tick this to be true, you'll see down in the bottom left hand side here that
an eye is exposed.
This is just a quick indication so that we can see which of the variables are made instance
editable.
We can also see if I hit compile and jump back into the level in the details panel,
we can now see that we have the spawnable meshes as a array that we can add elements
into on within the actors details.
So I could come in here and I'm going to add in the bush.
So the SM underscore bush.
So we already have one asset up ready.
Now we're going to need a couple more.
Next up, if I'm going to add an extra variable, and this is going to be the radius.
This is the radius in which the meshes will be scattered.
So in a drop down here, I'm going to select a float.
Now allow us to enter a value for how large the ray scatter radius will be.
Now this we don't want to be an array.
So I'm going to convert that back to a single and I'm going to click on the eye this time.
So that's going to make this instance editable as well.
Now we need another variable.
And this is going to be the spawn amount.
This is how many meshes will be spawned.
Now this is not going to need a decimal point.
So I'm just going to do a drop down and I'm going to change this into an integer.
And again, I'm going to click on the eye to make that instance editable.
If I hit compile and jump back into the level, you can now see that all of these variables are now accessible within the menu.
If I wanted to set a default amount, if I can jump into radius, you can see here we have a default value in the details panel.
I could start off by making that 300.
And if you have the spawn amount, I'm going to start off by making that five.
Compile.
And you'll now see that the values are updated within the details panel.
However, they can be overwritten.
At any point, I could update it to 10 or increase the radius.
So this is how we're going to control how the tool spawns the meshes.
Let's jump back into the tool here.
And we're going to do the work on the construction script.
So I'm going to grab the spawn amount to start with.
I'm going to drop that down and select get.
I'm going to drag off the construction script and look for a for loop.
See the bottom here, we have a for loop.
Now I'm going to connect the spawn amount into the last index and the first index I'm going to change to one.
This function will repeat dependent on the value of the spawn amount.
If this would be set to zero, it wouldn't repeat at all.
Let's say this would be set to five.
It's going to go around five times.
The reason we've changed the index to one is because a for loop standardly starts at zero,
meaning that if we set the amount to five, we would get six out.
It's just to reduce it down by one.
Next up, we are going to add a static mesh component.
So this is just going to create a static mesh component as part of this actor.
And we want to do this for each iteration here.
So we've connected it to the loop body.
Now I want to set the transform.
I'm going to need to do some calculations on this.
So the first thing I'm going to do is come up to this orange pin, which is a transform.
It's a struct of location, rotation and scale.
I'm going to right hand click and hit the split struct pin.
And that's going to give me the individual pin for both the location, rotation and scale.
I'm going to split this down even further.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to right hand click on the location and split the struct pin again,
giving me an individual pin for each X, Y and Z.
And we want to randomly place these.
To do this, we're going to use the random unit vector.
And what this will do is it will generate me a random vector between minus one and one on each X, Y and Z.
So it's going to be a very small vector.
And afterwards, what I'm going to do is I'm just going to multiply this.
I type in star, grab multiply.
I'm going to change this to a float.
So I right hand click and select float single precision.
I can drag in our radius and plug that in.
So what that's done is that has generated a random vector and then it's multiplied it by the radius so that we've made it bigger.
However, at the moment, this is going to generate it in any direction.
So I'm going to split the output here.
So I come in again and go split struct pin.
I'm going to plug the X and the Y in, but I'm going to ignore the Z so that we know that this is going to be on a flat plane.
The final thing I'd like to do is I would like to randomize the rotation a bit, but not on all of the axes.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to right hand click on our rotation and split this pin.
So we have another three floats.
And I am going to search for the function random.
Rotator.
I'm going to split this struct pin here.
I'm just going to grab the Z and add that in.
So you can see what this is doing is it's going in and it's giving us a random location only on the X and Y, and it's also randomizing the Z rotation.
Finally, we've added a static mesh component.
However, we haven't actually set the mesh.
So let's do that now.
So if we drag off and we type in set static mesh, it's important that you drag off of the blue pin to get this.
Come up here.
Now, if we drag in the spawnable meshes and get the spawnable meshes.
Now, since this is an array, we may have multiple entries in this spawnable meshes.
So therefore, we want to randomize the one that we get.
So I'm going to drag off and I'm going to type get a copy.
I'm going to plug that in.
What this is allowing us to do is to use an index, a number of the array to get one of the copies of the meshes from this spawnable mesh.
Now, we want to randomize this value, but in order to randomize this value, we first need to get the length of this array.
So I'm going to drag off and type in length.
Now, I can grab a random integer value in range.
Now, we want to.
Now, we want to actually use this length as the max.
So I'm going to hold down the control key and drag that so it plugs into them.
And I am going to make minimum one.
In order to get this to match up with the array, I am going to need to subtract one.
After I've done this, I'll drag that in and press compile.
So if we look at what we've done here, first thing is, is we are going to loop around for the amount dependent on the spawn amount variable.
And then once we've done that, we're going to add a static mesh component and we're randomizing the location within the radius.
And we are going to randomize the rotator so that it looks a little bit more natural.
Finally, we are setting the static mesh by grabbing the array and we're getting a value of the array of a random value based on how long the array is.
And we're going to set that mesh.
Let compile and save and jump back in.
We can already see that this is working.
So we have because we only have one mesh and see that we have only bushes that are being created in here.
However, if I was to hold down alt and drag off a second version and add something extra to the spawnable meshes, in this case, I'm going to select the chair.
We got the SM underscore chair.
And all that for the time being, we can now see that this is randomizing the chairs as well.
And there are a number of other settings, like we could increase the spawn amount to considerably larger and we could reduce the radius to compress it down.
So you can see here, this is straight away on construction script.
We're just randomizing out these meshes.
So that is our first tool.
Hopefully, you've managed to follow along and create that.
In the next video, we're going to be advancing the tool a little bit more so that it queries the environment, allowing us to stick the objects
that we're scattering to the ground.
As you can see here, if I drag this over, it's not paying any attention to where the ground is at all.
OK, so thanks for sticking with us.
I'll see you in the next video.